federal investigators are looking at new
clues about the final moments of the
helicopter flight that ended in tragedy
for nine people including Kobe Bryant
newly surfaced video taken not long
before the crash appears to show the
aircraft in mid-flight before it ran
into very serious trouble
our transportation correspondent that's
Kris Van Cleave is in Calabasas
California Kris it's so hard to look at
this video what are investigators
learning Miguel good morning the real
hard work of this investigation really
just beginning we do know the helicopter
did not have a terrain avoidance warning
system or a black box it wasn't required
to have either of those but it does make
it a little bit more challenging for
investigators they have recovered an
iPad that may have belonged to the pilot
and a cell phone at the scene they're
going to go through those they also
found maintenance records from the
helicopter in the wreckage those are
being analyzed but the big question why
did the helicopter fall from the sky
remains a mystery minutes from disaster
new cell phone video appears to show
Kobe Bryant's helicopter circling near
Burbank Airport before the crash Tuesday
the NTSB used a helicopter to airlift
the wreckage off the hillside
the coroner says all nine victims have
now been recovered and four have been
positively identified including Kobe
Bryant this was a high-energy impact
crash about 35 minutes after takeoff
with the weather deteriorating pilot
aras abuyin asked controllers to track
him on radar but he was flying too low
four minutes later he radioed he was
going to go above the layer of clouds
flying and potentially blinding fog
he reached 2,300 feet in its final 12
seconds of flight the helicopter banked
left and abruptly descended falling at
up to 5,000 feet per minute it's last
recorded speed about 184 miles per hour
do you have a sense if the helicopter
came down all in one piece or is there
evidence that it perhaps broke up as it
was coming down preliminary information
is that the helicopter was in one piece
when it impacted the terrain and there
were only a few minutes flight away from
their destination the Camarillo Airport
here at the crash scene one thing that
came up at the press conference is
hitting a lot of buzz was
this idea that they were 25 30 feet from
clearing a ridge the area where the
crash happened is a series of ridges and
ravines and the rate at which they were
coming down that helicopter was going to
crash whether it cleared that Ridge or
not Anthony all right Chris thanks